bonjour à tous Aujourd'hui je vais vous
montrer comment diffuser votre CV sur la
plateforme emploi 86.com et multipliez
vos chances de trouver un nouveau job
pour cela c'est très simple sur la page
d'accueil du site vous allez vous
connecter à l'espace candidat et si
toutefois vous n'avez pas encore créé un
compte ce n'est pas grave un simple mail
et mot de passe suffit pour accéder à
notre site dans votre espace vous allez
sélectionner mon espace CV et vous
trouverez deux fonctionnalités
essentielles la première c'est un outil
de création de CV vous rentrez vos
références et plus besoin de mettre en
forme c'est l'outil qu'il fait à votre
place mais sans vous le montrera dans
une prochaine vidéo la deuxième c'est la
fonction BCV et c'est elle qui nous
intéresse aujourd'hui par défaut votre
CV n'est pas visible car le rgpd
nécessite votre accord alors si vous
voulez vous offrir l'opportunité d'être
contacté par un recruteur n'attendez
plus diffusez votre CV maintenant votre
CV est en ligne et vous mettez toutes
les chances de votre côté bien entendu
vous pouvez revenir en arrière autant de
fois que vous le souhaitez
la prochaine fois je vous montrerai
comment créer un CV rapidement sur notre
plateforme alors à très bientôt sur un
blog 86.com une initiative du
département de la Vienne